uh brandon is with us in austin texas
good afternoon brandon how can christy
and i help
brandon good how are you guys doing
doing good man
how can we help bro i have i had a
question
so we have my wife and i have house paid
off
no student loans no credit card the only
debt we have
is our two vehicles okay uh we have the
cash and savings but
vehicles are one of those things i hate
spending money on because they
immediately the day after you pay them
off
are already worth less than what you
paid for
uh should we continue to finance those
or pay them off okay let's talk talk to
me about them um how much do you own
both the cars
i have about fifty thousand on both of
them between the two of them
okay so fifty thousand dollars in cars
how much do you have in your savings
right now
um we've got about sixty five thousand
dollars in the savings
okay so we got about 65k in savings all
right
and this is your only debt so no student
loans
no credit cards nothing just fifty
thousand dollars
in uh car loans correct
all right cool great let me answer this
question why do you want to keep paying
interest on something on a depreciating
asset
i mean the interest is low enough that
it's always been one of those things
that
i felt better to save the cash than to
invest into a vehicle that would be
worth
less the next day if you were to get a
wreck or something were to happen
so even if your interest is at one
percent two percent you do understand
that you're paying more money on the car
that you're saying is depreciating so
wouldn't you rather save yourself
money in the long run uh
and pay it off
yeah i guess that makes sense yeah i
mean it doesn't change the numbers the
interest was low
yeah you know i mean it doesn't change
the numbers if you own it or if it's
financed the value of the car is going
to be the value of the car the value of
the car is not dictated by how it's
financed yeah
the va you're just kind of playing this
game with yourself right you know what i
mean so it's like
let's just pay it off you've got the
money paid off and also man
brandon it's gonna feel so good to be
completely debt-free like you're
right there you're one click away yeah
from being completely debt-free
including your house that's insane
and you've got 15 grand left over in
savings like you're gonna be in a sweet
spot i think it's just that last it's
almost like a security blanket it's like
oh i'm so comfortable i'm used to this i
feel good about it
we gotta we gotta go if you're gonna
grow outside of this
you're gonna have to get a little bit
uncomfortable from your old ways of
doing things but it's gonna be so worth
it i tell people all the time brandon
the voice of debt is always the voice of
regret and whenever you pay that off
you're gonna feel more free than you've
ever felt in your life then you can just
keep adding to that savings and you can
do anything you want to absolutely it's
a good feeling
brandon hang up the phone from us man go
pay off your car you got it
right now do it all right
in two minutes brandon's about to be
totally different exactly and if you do
it within the next two minutes call us
back let's do a
free stream